[Music]
welcome welcome
CIA lords Marquez episode number 74 it
is another losing Sunday moving baby
better glorious today and we are back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I am very excited about a special guest
so we're gonna get right into it I want
to introduce the Lord who our first
crossed paths with do some good
old-fashioned xbox live gaming and party
chat this Lord's journey and growth in
the community has been absolutely
remarkable to watch whether it be his
balance opinion pieces
cool music innovation or unique live
streams all done with fantastic
production values introducing the host
of the next level podcast and panelists
of the crossfire podcast the Lord of
video game console neutrality and one of
the most passionate gamers you ever
encounter while kidding it's vape on
making his debut into the realm of the
Lord's my man what's going on Lord X
what's going on people King is in the
building
whoa dude you are giving me a run for my
money when it comes to these intros man
thank you thank you for the kind words I
do appreciate it it's it's been a long
time coming man but I am on I LP weave
it gave it with X bar for a long time it
had to be done you guys brought me
through my first rain and everything man
you had a Forza horizon claim that I
think I joy you know say I think one of
y'all guys yeah last one like far knows
where I was really big Arista Rock how
it gave and stuff like that I used to
always tell X bar he need to convert his
challenge or is it her eyes
channel it's not like one of those
things you know where you will have
content every year they have for every
yeah but just good like I said it's long
overdue to have you in a room your
absolute Lord and what's she doing
so it's only right to have that the
roundtable you got it ready to get
rocking my time down then I saw the
topics let's let's go go and of course
what level is his characters are because
he been slacking I got a three ninety
three hundred right now sweets doors
everybody have four hundred a four five
will you add those times you did the
prestige honor egg layers men I got
seventeen clears okay that's where I got
to catch up man but I've been trying to
do right now I gotta get all three
characters up into that at the rail
table my co-host with the cold most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror and the house
of the young wolf mommy Lord addict how
you doing sir doing pretty good are you
guys do talking determine is whether you
had a five hour and you adjust every
episode this is like based on your
energy guitar how to show go go with you
of course we have our most ethical
gaming Lord the solo game who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra darkness mister often
our proof
Illuminati and Lord patreon of the iron
bank mommy
North sovereign are you doing sir I'm
doing fantastic guys how you guys doing
Rock is solving a building Attica to
build let's go real quick all one that
we had during the course of the week we
had some one more patreon subscriber
good dear friend to the round this man
has known kognito and myself since
kindergarten like so big shout out to
Lourdes loaded loaded pixels loading
pixels babe no down much we go way back
he works down the block that's what's up
and of course you know we got the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
oh the lord of combat sports who was a
man of his convictions demands nothing
less than that premium experience and is
to get money game up oh we love it Lord
King how you doing sir I'm so happy that
you here because I can't get you to join
a RAID with us I'll be spamming invites
his way I know he's sealed pop up on the
screen I just want to give a shout out
to Tiger he through Kylie Jenner in the
bushes and his music is better sohow
shout out you sir
because he has some three songs that are
pounding that ISM rotation yes
yeah he got the joint cream he got Swiss
she got dad joint yup he back he back he
back from the day cuz he was in the
walking dead a minute ago he was a
zombie he was in a sunken place yo guys
if I can I need I need to I need to you
know secure my name is king neutral
right now when King said that I was
ducking him or whatnot see I'm also
putting my hand out there for people who
haven't done I'm a man of the people you
know Eddie snake oil salesman Hearn is
out head
everybody please I want you to put a
bunch of bushes emoji okay if you're
doing that for me attic might want want
me on like every week as a special guest
just so you skip through that you know
get through his difficult game
conquering there's nobody care for it I
just look at you I got somebody in the
lane playing that game the shinobi Lord
God knows where their realness in the
realm of the IOP now telling you what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear so before we get into what the
Lords are playing this week I want to
start off with Lord Xbox his videogame
system history because Johnny into
YouTube and the podcast run with that
next podcast and then eventually what
led him to becoming a panelist on
crossfire
so Lord Xbox let's take it back to the
beginning with some of the verse first
video game systems you had and what got
you together well the the first system I
actually owned was the NES and I was
nice
I used to my dad's Atari from time to
time as well and I was a big pitfall fan
I love that game and I got addicted I
would play that game until until I would
get yelled at you know what I'm saying
like get off the TV true daehwa but NES
I played a lot of games with my older
brother at the time he was into a lot a
lot of like airplane helicopter stuff so
I was playing like Tiger Halley of
course like traditional Mario Zelda all
that good stuff but because of my older
brother I was getting into the kind of
like helicopter combat and stuff like
that we had we had a blast playing
together okay let's see after that man
it was the genesis my brother my brother
had the Genesis I had the Super Nintendo
so I was able to get the best of both
worlds on that brother and he went all
in like he got the Genesis and when the
Sega CD came out the big one that you
put on yeah he had it he grabbed that he
had the 32x so I was I to the plate like
all all three of those things put
together my Super Nintendo for some
reason my older brother didn't want to
play any of that I don't
he thought he saw me killing it with you
no my boy the hose loom and he was like
he doesn't he didn't want nothing with
that long-gone action after that I went
I went to Dreamcast and I gotta say to
this day let's go Dreamcast is probably
my favorite console man innovation yeah
I'm not to cut you that because there's
so many people we have on ILP always
ranked the Dreamcast up there very
interesting here you say them but you
tell me about the innovation that we
have so many people wrong I also had a
playstation man and I gotta say my
Playstations like I rocked that like I
played the police station once so hard
that I had to turn it upside down after
a while when your lens got messed up now
you were there were a number of
different things you could do to try to
get that to work better but yes I ways
like I said Dreamcast was to this day
was my number one console having the the
VM use and having the little games that
you can play like I remember being I
used to work at a store called stop and
shop I used to work in the deli well it
depends like I know everybody in the
chat mandate they nationwide you know
tri-state big took it that shot I was
working in the deli every like 15-minute
break or half-hour break I was working
on my Chows in Sonic Adventure and stuff
like that they had they had the
peripheral where you know you would go
fishing it actually had the rod to it
game see man see I want to try to get
some people fish with the man face yeah
really quick people clown me on that you
know what I'm saying
but Jersey words hey let's get those
likes up we have 42 and I only see 17
let's see but after that you know I got
my first Xbox I didn't really mess with
the PlayStation 2 or the PlayStation 3
now the reason why I didn't really get a
ps2 was um I had friends that we used to
hang out on the daily and my boy John he
had the ps2 so I was able to play it
whenever I wanted to I didn't think I
had to invest enough I had my Dreamcast
you know he had he had that you know I
also had a 64 as well wrestling and
wrestling no mercy they did not have the
best they haven't been able to match it
since next this day oh and I think it
was the conversion over to disk that
somehow someway they lost they lost
something in that now the graphics has
been great on wrestling games lately but
nothing compares to the gameplay of like
the 64 wrestlemania 2000 facts and that
was d out the a key engine corrects off
yep those are the one of the most
balanced in the counter system remember
they used to stick they chess out the
cat of the book yeah what a chest how
it's the block remember you counter you
count it just like you did like in
quickness like right Andy like when you
get up off the ground like a safe
getaway oh yeah you were crouched and
then you could you could clothesline if
we have video of the epic matches that
we had back in the day
it had millions of views on you
and then the last thing to order 64
resignated you really really touched
this knowledge about for me he's like
this ice thickness of the battle way you
got eliminated and you go we try to grab
like everybody you can hate after the
loss like that was so funny ad is so
much strategy because you had to make
sure to stay away from these guys you
had to try to do your bit let me go from
from that into like YouTube now the
start of this generation
I was watching like gaming media and
stuff you know talking about the two
consoles I saw the unveiling of both
consoles and I've been on record stating
that the original idea for the Xbox one
was something I was interested in but I
do know when Microsoft looks into the
future sometimes they look a little
farther than everybody else
and and not a lot of people accept you
know what is coming down the line
because they look so far ahead you know
down the road but I was down for that so
I already knew I was going to get it
Xbox um
but was it all that I saw this whole
kind of like power narrative building up
I saw this whole kind of like resolution
war starting to build and stuff and you
know with this generation we have game
DVR not only do we have game DVR but you
can upload to YouTube you know you could
stream to twitch and stuff like that so
they really they handed out tools to the
gamer where you didn't have to go get
like an elgato or you know spend $150
here so to spend $100 here and you could
just stream or you can record video so I
was like you know what I'm gonna throw
my hat into the ring here nice hopefully
I could bring some common sense you know
to the YouTube gaming department back it
wasn't a lot then like dude honks people
were throwing out misinformation here
and there and
it was absolutely crazy people it became
so popular just to bash the Xbox one and
not look at the games that were there
and the experiences that they were
creating on that system so touching I
started my channel um you know I did a
lot of Forza as well I I knew I do car
vinyls and stuff like that I was putting
that out there I was showing like new
cars I was making making a move that
like the designs available for free
I've seen those those are tight I
remember that yeah I'm actually gonna
get back into that as well I got a
couple more I got a couple carves that
I'm planning on kind of like live
streaming and and showing kind of the
process or whatnot and putting those
vinyls together but um after a while I
started getting close to a thousand subs
in my boy mooch gets all over me okay uh
asked me to be a special guest on
crossfire Oh move to the crossfire team
we pretty much get a lot of crossfire
which is really good at finding people
man like he really does he goes through
YouTube he watches people's videos and
stuff like that um he's the one who gave
me my first shot on a live podcast what
happened was um I was a special guest
and everything went everything went cool
I was a little intimidated your first a
heavyweight holding your own I was
trying to get two words in but after
that like it really kind of that itch
got to me and I and I started like every
like maybe week or two I would send mu 2
DM like y'all if you need somebody I'm
here if you hate somebody I'm here
eventually he got me back on and I
remember that when he introduced me on
the second time I was like cuz I told
everybody in the chat I was like yo he
let me back in the door and now I've
gotta use that boot to kick the alley
I'm trying to be here every week now
it's funny here people first start is
very similar with youth otherwise like
home you know you're getting Ivan credit
addict like you know I was like okay
you get it through it and then you kind
of get that it you get that feet but if
you were to keep it here it going so I
know what you mean so Luke the law of
mooching it because like I said we've
had a lot of crossfire also I want to
shout out Italian clowns that's the
homie um give them some love yeah so
it's like you know it's it's funny to
see like you know how people get in and
then like they have that passport and
that's one of your trademarks like
anybody who watches the next mic if you
don't hear the passion this man like
this man loves game good to see you know
saying your journey and what's going on
but continue story I'm sorry yeah well
when it comes to crossfire my main goal
was I've seen a lot of people be a
special guest and wit crack gamer their
crap gamer has yes a tendency to talk
and really get his opinion out there I
wanted to be I wanted to be kind of like
his kryptonite on that I wanted to make
sure that I would come in I do I I
remember is like I was known for
interrupting crap and that is so hard to
do man
he's wised up from it as of lately and
he just keeps talking over me no matter
what yeah I noticed that today man a lot
and I was like what is he gonna catch on
he's not when it comes to next podcast
me and and my brother came mega will
talk yes okay Meg we met him out there
anything man good passion man you talk
about heart you you can definitely put K
mega on that list I wanted to do a show
I want to do something different I've
seen a lot of hangouts and stuff like
that people coming together talking
gaming which is great you know what I'm
saying yeah absolutely I wanted
something that people could be able to
watch as well so we came up with the
idea of everybody on the panel given
about 10-15 minutes of gameplay like
the attic attic remember we try to do
that with aim DVR vo and made it simple
I was thinking only Xbox but now with
with my brother predator and and K mega
on there and they dabble in PC game in
mandate we get we get such a wide range
of games you can watch you know
everybody's game play you can vote for
the best gameplay at the end of the show
on my Twitter long and it's just become
this thing where it's not just you know
you're hearing the gaming opinions on
the gaming news but you actually have
something to watch you can you can chime
in on the chat about like who had the
best gameplay what was this person
thinking here doing this and stuff like
that it's been a lot of fun man yeah and
I want to give you a lot of credit
because it is such a unique take on it
and like I said I love how you guys set
that up and and like I said I don't
people don't understand like a lot of
stuff takes work and you know yesterday
I he was you know we're still starting
we're still growing and just to see your
journey with that kind of thing I think
it's also don't think you get enough
credit like with the music integration
you have no beats popping it's like it's
just cool to see how you do the overlays
it's a unique thing you know shout to
chat a game a boy dad says hey next
podcast is an April show
yes salutes you guys look to the team
and so gimme gimme maybe the shoutouts
for the whole roster you got Kate mate
shout your teen man oh yeah of course
with the piano we got we got my brother
K mega we got we got oh snaps it's know
who she's more of a part-time because of
her job so she gets in when she can um
we got the angry otter himself we call
him the angry otter aka dark Goldblum
but he is dark animus of course we have
the developer that everybody loves the
dawn you know every very formative year
very very good um my boy predator when
it comes predator and and dark autumn
asar two of the newer people on the
panel and I got a statement I gotta give
them huge shoutouts cuz we we start our
DMS like early in the week and I and I
asked people like what do they want to
talk about you know as a week goes and
and Adam miss and predator
are on their game and there they're
constantly putting articles in there are
we we just did on the show this past
Saturday and we were talking about EA
finally using quote unquote morality yes
whether or not whether or not their
games would have loot crate's I haven't
seen anybody else talk about that and if
it wasn't for for Adam miss and predator
I don't would have such a wide range of
topics going in oh but they say what has
Don developed they go in there like we
got it we got a respect Don out hey
what's going on well doc I'm just doing
a project now he's calling it project
pimp Cup it says it's his first game you
guys know in the gaming industry you
have people that kind of come in on
short term contracts and and work on
certain things within games um I I know
he's been kind of like freelance moving
from I I believe like EA and other
places and and doing like these these
small contracts but he's looking to hit
kind of like the big time and drop his
own game yeah definitely like the
discussion when you guys talk about a
very knowledgeable very informative
talks man and like I said you guys have
really good chemistry so that's cool so
one personal question before we move
into the question I ask every other
guest so for you why I got I got the X
part I think as a play I'm assuming
that's like a play on what was going on
with console wars and all that matters
but then tell me what the four four
eight what's the fall for that a that
ain't no CT area Cobra no no no 203 or
eight six zero in scene III I am a weird
person man I like to learn stuff on a
daily basis and one thing I got into was
certain sets of numerology right so 4
means like the creation or the beginning
of something and basically um what King
about to drop some knowledge right yeah
we start there in a party chat one day
and shut everybody in a punch
if you want to talk about two conspiracy
theorists that's what you want to label
as we roll in this faint bushes together
this man yes is 100% on the same page so
we was dropping knowledge and he's about
to draw he brought the finish dropping
now that I already know about it but
he's about to finish knowledge when we
drop a knowledge so much in that chat
then the loud with that wisdom therefore
8 knowledge yourself let's get there
well the number 4 stands for like the
beginning and and an 8 is is kind of
like a number that stands for rebirth so
when I when I was looking at what was
going on the gaming industry I thought
we needed the beginning of change I
thought we need the beginning of
something better and so you know I just
put that into my name of course like you
said X spot when I saw people like oh
you're an X Y or your Pony and stuff
like that I was like people start
calling me X but just because I played
on the Xbox and I was like you know what
that's a cool [ __ ] name I rather be
called that than anything else I can
make that like something cool I can make
that look cool and stuff like that I had
a lot of like robot type things when I
first started my channel um and and I
don't know it just it stuck with me it
just stayed me no I thought it was a
great killer this very Jeff acknowledge
right there bill does I got you pretty
much like that and then the play play on
the name and then for me it's like kind
of like personal source numerology in
things that it personally meet you oh
yeah no doubt that's what service of
course and gotta ask you to the
important questions in the brown so um
let's start with like the top 5 games
Xbox games of all time either the games
or franchise your top 5 or top
of all time well yeah I already give you
my number one I've said it across the
board my number one game all time is for
Super Nintendo and it is Super Metroid
alright woo I didn't know it was a
Metroid Hey
oh dude Super Metroid do i I lost like
like probably a whole like school year
not nothing but that game and I that was
the first game I really went into like
hard after I beat it and everything like
that I remember going to be be at the
time and getting the strategy book in
case I missed anything and I went back
in I don't know how many more times just
just getting everything from the
strategy book as well so that that was
else we got what else we got um in terms
of franchises I got to put halo up there
uh I've been a huge huge Halo fan for a
long time ever since the first one the
first time I played halo was at my
cousin's house and he just gave me the
controller it was a big-ass hamburger
controller Duke that big Duke but I took
over like the game that had his save and
it was we just land into this like huge
cavern and I could not believe the size
of this man and then you know I was
going in first person shooter getting
getting kind of like the sticks right
because if you remember it was a lot
different than like Goldeneye and I was
used to sold and I yeah in terms of
first-person so this was different
you're using one stick to move legs
another one to move the head and you
know I had to get used to that but you
know like I was had a family
get-together at my aunt's house and I
was just there in my cousin's room the
entire time playing Halo I was hooked I
knew I had to get Xbox that day that was
a lot of us a lot of us felt the same
way so that's - we got super Metro we
got Halo 3 more well we'll go we'll go
with the Forza franchise see I grew I
grew up like I said when I had to play
station it would Gran Turismo me and me
and my boy
kill gran turismo a little realistic now
GTT what if first night clips
I remember my Mercedes watch those
replays all day it would just look like
real life like back then on PlayStation
like it was crazy
continuing yeah and but to see the
evolution now and to see what turn 10
has done with this franchise they like
they took that mantle and they they
pushed it forward you know next level I
don't know what's going on with Gran
Turismo sport I know a lot of people out
there do like the game and I'm not I'm
not saying yeah you shouldn't but coming
from the original Gran Turismo I'm
wondering what happened with the scene
like this is interesting
I mean it's definitely definitely Forza
turn 10 and a playground with the
horizon series those guys taking a man
to and pushed it to the next level so I
mean they gotta put for them to be on
the same level they would have to
release games more regularly and they
don't they take their time game per
decade you know you're not gonna you're
not gonna be able to keep up mm-hmm and
that's another thing what turn 10 you
saw like you you you brought up the
horizon series as well like when they're
they're doing racing simulations and
that's popular and stuff like that they
were listening to the gamers out there
and and you know they worked out a deal
with playground who wasn't first party
at the time to make an open world kind
of like a a car enthusiast game and that
turned out to be yeah I think this is
gonna be I think horizons gonna be
bigger than motorsport in the long run
you know it caters to a wider range of
gamer out there a you know car
enthusiast open-world like they just
they have a lot going for her isin next
on the list man I gotta say I got throws
Elda in there as well when you're
talking top five like greatest you know
there's gonna there's gonna be a lot of
Nintendo in there because they basically
they built a foundation that even like
Microsoft is on it Sony they're building
on as well so you gotta go back to that
foundation direct inspired a law in the
industry oh yeah yeah
we have Zelda a lot in people's top 5
absolutely digital todrick said stop it
X bar Forza is arcade Gran Turismo was
that sim no comparison goes in and does
um and does their their their work on
like tired deterioration and stuff like
that and you don't see you don't see the
other side doing it you don't see their
rival doing it and getting into detail
to that point that's when I gotta say
you know what you you might want to
rethink that but those days if for the
70s sim is a civic a or they going in
the attack okay Oh Metroid is Elden
hello
halo and I got one more and when you
come down to number one like one left
that's when it gets really hard man and
I gotta say if if I'm going with kind of
like the flavor of the week or the
flavor of the year for me then I got I
gotta go with destiny to right now no
dude it's the one it's well it's the one
game I'm talking about right now
you don't know saying it's the one game
where when I turn on my xbox I can play
a Forza I can play a halo I can play so
many other games I've gained past as
well so I have like a huge library of
games to choose from and I go to destiny
to you know I'm biased right cuz I am
with destiny god but I gotta say I gotta
get at you you're saying yes to this
destiny one of the greatest of all time
well for right now like I like I'm going
with like what what I'm playing right
now you know what I'm saying I could
easily if I had to take that out of
there and put put an established
franchise in number five to me would
probably be doomed
okay doomed the doom franchise was was
really the first person shooter for me
um even to this day he saw was soon
eternal they are pushing that bar
further and further update the the the
next doom is looking incredible
I mean I would put that in there for all
time but in terms of what I'm playing
right now and what what I pick up the
controller and and I just grabbed it
consistently gives you that feeling yes
y'all for the people who hate on destiny
like what is it about destiny that is
like you just can't stop playing this
game because a lot of people know like
why are you guys playing that game y'all
still play that games day isn't it dad
like because like so tell the people
what is it about destiny that gets you
up and what everyday to play this game
well there's a couple things now first
off it deals with my kind of like klepto
side of things where I want absolutely
everything that this game has to offer
you don't really okay I'm going into
escalation protocol after this show I
need them the weapons before sleeper
cattle inside the clan because I've been
watching your behavior a Fonzarelli sir
I'm have to pull rank on you sir funny
about this King is talking about if I if
I play with clan members or not he's not
thinking about how many people I have
gotten to the clan but yeah just there's
just somebody gameplay stuff that can
get you so you said the your addictive
side what what else about that's it and
I guess another thing is kind of like
the camaraderie man because there's like
when you go when you go into the raid
it's not just everybody do something for
themselves like there's a communication
there there's there's certain things
that you have to do that is the best
cooperative experiences it's a different
experience than anything from any other
game and you really you really feel a
sense of like gratification when when
when you beat the raid with the crew
you're with us and connection yeah and
when when you can get it to the point
where you have like two or three new
people and you can still bring them
through parade and you hear the
excitement their voice that I don't get
from any other game right now see oh he
got me you got me go all right so we got
a move
but you're out with that that was a
serious okay that's and I'm gonna debut
this new thing for you and basically
it's gonna be we did the top five now
you don't have to put this and this
question in the specific order but top
five consoles of all time
Oh spot let's go all right so let's go
um I'm gonna go I'm gonna go from the
bottom up here let's see this is gonna
be he's gonna be tough man you guys
already know number one was it's gonna
be Dreamcast for me so we're going five
through two um I will go number five
Super Nintendo Super Nintendo man the
the library of games and the quality of
games at that point in time you can even
see with the the mini Super Nintendo
these games hold up today so that there
was that that was like the Golden Age of
of that type of graphic system there I
will go on Xbox one and number four well
no no not the one we have now right now
and the reason why the reason why is the
feature set and I do like um when they
came out with new exclusive with new IPs
there was something there that I liked
men when it came to sunset overdrive to
me that that is the game of this
generation in my eyes our Sony Lords are
gonna come for you right now yeah I know
there's a certain there's a certain got
a war game out they're going to question
you you look at you look at the the new
IPS that came out over here you know
quantum break is another game that I
thought looked absolutely stunning I
like I liked what they were trying to do
with the story in terms of the the game
the the game in the show and
they don't necessarily have to do that
but they were doing really kind of
reaching out there and trying something
new all right and I do know when it came
graphically that game was really hard to
make anything yeah when you had stuff
suspended in the sky but it was being
rippled like with visible ripples but
you can still move around like that that
game was hard turning so we got Xbox and
Xbox one in a much cooler I'll have to
go PlayStation one nice no dude
I remember putting in GTA when it was
over the top like it was over yo you had
the bird's-eye view but in the game in
and then being able to take the game out
and put a music disc in yes and then
every time you got into a car it would
play a song from your dish yes they did
so many things with the PlayStation 1
that I absolutely loved it was young
aggressive Sony making their mark
fantastic said I remember to boot up
sound right yeah all right so give it a
last one so this would be number two
number two all-time um I got it I gotta
go I gotta go with him and it's you
gotta make tough choices okay I'm gonna
go with my personal opinion here I'm
gonna go Genesis men salute yeah first
time I played Mortal Kombat you know
that wasn't in the arcade was on the
Genesis Sonic the Hedgehog
I am absolutely addicted to almost they
had games like Super Thunder blades yeah
I was hooked uh you know f-22
interceptor do I could go on and on with
the games like and a lot of it is is
personal because those are games that
mean my brother played you know what I'm
saying
I got a Cudi the chat is going Michael
second game of the Jenna race I had to
pull over and make sure my son didn't
either
facts this is what your personal
emotional connection to these systems
are that people got a big overdrive on I
can see other people not saying that but
for me I'm into like punk rock music I'm
into it in a certain sense of humor
gotcha
and it's like they took they took my
thought to my random thoughts and
everything and he made a game out of it
overdrive that's why for me that was the
experience this generation it was that
new that was the fire right there yes
sir all right man I was dope man so
thank you for participating in a new
segment you're making everybody squirm a
little make the tough choices to get
called out
I struggled last night I would debut it
but I couldn't I can't believe I'm
leaving you know how I ended up making
mine I said okay I gotta make some tough
calls so like you know I want to put
like 300 and me a couple people we need
him saying like 64 for me something I
feel about it so it's just right but
what I had to do for months I said okay
my personal experience like what Xbox he
took it to his heart like what made him
game the most on those consoles and the
second thing I'll also looked at
longevity because also there was some
systems that came out but it was like
they just had a short run you know me in
the burst so I'm just like I can't have
you I don't care I don't care what they
say they can say hey you gonna have to
give wishes sir and I do not want you to
come out there out of that bushes no
but yeah we go move on so we pretty much
got what you were playing like what X
bar you said you felt like destiny
obsolete there's okay so let's get it to
Lourdes attic management plan pretty
much just we happy for you and that's
all okay see be right we'll get to that
topic as well I can't wait to hear what
he thinks about that game yeah I'm very
curious about that Lord Sagi plan
playing all night talking about
Metroidvania and uh Super Metroid being
Xbox is a favorite game 3 right now that
have my attention on switch iconic class
it is hollow night and is that all goes
on around that just a disclaimer all my
opinion and I actually I didn't get to
play destiny get online to like now I'm
not playing destiny I'm not playing solo
destiny alright i sorry I was gonna
finish war mind ended up don't lie so I
I got to finish those aspects of those
like his voice is some good he plays it
don't don't let King fool you alright
well this week I got all my characters
to master works and destiny so we all
have full 5 we rockin out here got shout
out to all the clans mace to actually
play with each other but up X but I want
to give a big shout out to Jay
Fonzarelli because we was in the rain
and we definitely went through we
definitely had a good time so I want him
to understand that he's always welcome
every time we play he's do obey me he's
on PlayStation he's on spots that's what
I'm saying he got two full time destiny
jobs went from destiny because I did all
my stuff there so I ran back to my
second love oh ji-ho
man that update that game is running so
late it's
it's good right he said he said clean
invites out no responses you straight
fraud all right I'm gonna look you in
your eyes and tell you you straight
fraud
you know any time I'm doing something
I'm calling for brat always owe you my
man all frauding right now don't let me
blow up that spot you fraud rap saying
wax well he can't be in the Klan cut
that out cut that out you wanted at 30
frames per second we were in a 60 rap is
a bit in the party chest you know Thank
You mr. Lister Jay Fonzarelli knows
rap is nowhere to be found traveller I
started it up on yesterday because I had
to go into work or whatever and cover
some bases over there so while I had two
hours a kill switch yeah I don't what
you call that I don't buy digital
downloads mostly if I can get the game
physical core really like that so you
know I got it I updated it right then
and I shot out and um I had to take my
glasses because the text is so small but
you don't really need to read the text
because everything is vocal but that
game took me back to one of my best
games as Final Fantasy 3 and death
feeling loved playing that game I was
like oh they hit the nail on the head it
was retro but it's a current yeah and I
said man this game I know I said I'm
going home and I'm you're not gonna see
me on destiny for like a little couple
of hours in the day but I'm gonna give
time to that game because that's a they
they got it it's like they you know how
Xmas just said we will with sunset
overdrive like they got it yeah I was
craving for this type of game hmm
I know somebody says long-winded when
they're talking yeah I want that moku's
is why I like okay you know what that's
interesting you get the inflection of
the character what no not Sega CD not
Sega CD I purchased it for turbo graphic
CD oh yeah that's when the first time I
saw fullscreen cartoon and voice yeah
this is that's just definitely to pass
if you got a switch and you want that
Japanese RPG real feel like that
old-school current mmm go get it go go
get it and play it go get it
I like for me I'm obviously been work
live getting in ways I've been online
laughs this week but um future is I got
I've been rocking crucible I gotta tell
the next pot earlier you know said did a
little bit of sorceress armor but this
this following I'm gonna get back on my
desert for that crucible they're doing
people dirty on that go show would be
something yeah yo you know why they did
that Xbox so everybody gets everything
you know you know you know why did you
know why this this weekend they debuted
that or they had that going on and they
had escalation protocol and all this
other stuff popping in anyway I've
noticed Call of Duty came out stay out
of each other's way
enemy under no but I saw my friends list
all right because it was very sweet yeah
mmm job and it's that double xp and then
it came back
yes want that go show cuz it's got the
faction consumables that ya Campina in
strikes and on the scene go show yummy
and UX by had talk about that how
important it is it's like that we kind
of feel like everybody everybody go rut
but up food you says I've been doing
that I'm trying to get if you are doing
an escalation protocol off the de jure
I'm definitely which are I need to get
those armed guns so that I can get to
sleep us to simulate I want I think the
armor looks incredible so for me is all
about a shout out on friends of the road
Mikey and he happy X what he had put up
a picture of the Reg exclaim would he
just got talk like somebody's only like
what 5,000 like it's just so just only
like a little less than 3,000 people
right now have that thing out of the
entire day you know small it is so I'm
on my ground with that you know
clanmates let's go if not y'all gonna
have me use ornament more oh man come on
facts
I'm serious are we doing that so yeah be
jelly with that but I'm back on the
underground so let's get into this pose
get the show moving alright so last
week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question but
the continued financial success of
Nintendo's mini consoles do you
ultimately think this will negatively
affect the success of Nintendo switch
moving forward history was made today
Lords the winner at 37% in the Titus 3
wait ILP poll ever was the I don't care
the Nintendo online app is trash the
shallowest Lords have one and I am
people coveted at a razor close second
place at 33% with the Nintendo switch
was already on the decline girl
and sadly for us off at 30% with the
switch software still dominates NPD
Group thanks all you awful terrible
lords who participated in what in the
world do the lords think about it you
want to know what I mean did anyone
expect
oh yeah King there's a lot of people
with high up you teachers out there now
[Laughter]
XD just which I just like we don't even
care what's the largest trash well I
it's just so it just shows that you know
how far we've come in gaming and and
what people expect from a gaming you
gotta have a stable online
infrastructure you know if you want to
call your when I heard like you guys if
you follow me at all you know I called
the switch I say it is the strongest it
is the most powerful tablet out there I
call it a handheld then and that's what
it is
and if they didn't use the word console
with this I don't think people would be
expecting as much in terms of like what
what Xbox or what PlayStation gives to
people the foundation of features there
and and that's what it's it's kind of
biting them in the ass you know no it's
about - and not plus with them they own
the - that
is a cake told everybody to vote 5-cc or
he throw them in a bus no that's all bad
[Laughter]
way like at least $20 whatever I get I
get what in the world to burn so it's
like when I literally left I'm so happy
right now to these tactics men and this
one I'm gonna be richer like I didn't
want to I didn't want to even cover this
it's been being today they all know
about the Arjun plagiarism fiasco and
yet some new developments happened and
it's the gift that keeps on giving
you know we're gonna start from the
beginning um alright law so help me out
here because I've seen yet the former
IGN editor cannot pronounce his last
name Philip you see okay so right he was
the editor
you know the review of the game in
question was dead cells and the youtuber
that this whole thing kind of originated
with was boomstick gimme for the record
that's not all be loved mister mad
people hit my dad I'm gonna put you out
there cat daddy was so funny
[Laughter]
like they you're all I hope he was on
deck with the Hammers like no they did
not
go for all boomstick Excel you know say
so is that mister boom X Dale from
crossfire our peeps yo se but it's
boomstick gaming and you know basically
you know let's get it let's get it down
for the begun I myself just set it up
and then I'm gonna everybody kind of get
into it but um let's see did you see the
actual video of boo sticks are yeah I
saw the boom sticks video i G ends dead
so review came out a few days after
boomstick and then boomstick put up a
big video saying IgM plagiarized my dead
cells review what should I do and in the
video he went step by step scene by
scene saying what was plagiarizing what
was and and the thing about it is for
Philip mucin what he did was he changed
wording he changed certain things about
what was said but don't employer ISM
obviously if you copy word-for-word
that's gonna be seen right and the
second most obvious thing is that when
your ideas follow suit exactly what's
with the original author that's that
that's a dead giveaway that you're
copying because if you put a hundred
people in a room and ask them to write
three paragraphs about the same thing no
two people's ideas are gonna follow suit
the same way it's not gonna happen
people don't think the same way right
people are gonna write differently so
the fact that that his ideas followed
exactly what boomsticks did that was a
huge red flag so he put that up that
gained a lot of traction and it got back
to IGN to the point where i GN decided
to pull their dead cells review and
investigate and within 24 hours they had
2:24 they wanted to make sure they got
out there and and had a unified message
arm and 24 hours later Philip Newton had
been late
go armed and they said you know they
said what they're supposed to say that
that that is absolutely a hundred
percent against what they're about armed
they had you know honestly for them it's
one of those things where they trust
their writers and they never thought
they would have to do something like
this right so overall let's start let's
start with a lord xbox forest absolutely
know about situation you know I'm saying
then we had the video and all subsequent
stuff but um like what was your take on
this thing
Lord XY like once the news broke all
right um no you guys got to know how I
feel about big like gaming media this
generation I feel like they have been
completely slanted all the way oh yeah
yeah there is something like that out
there man believe it or not like I'm
even starting a new a new podcast within
the next month or so that's gonna it's
gonna focus more on kind of like the
up-and-coming youtubers the people who
are building their channels because
they're tired of the IGN's the
GameSpot's and stuff like that and I
really want to bring a focus on those
youtubers coming up well it didn't
surprise me men and and I don't I I
don't think that it's just this one
person either I think there's a lot of
actions when it comes to these big
gaming media sites there's a lot of
things that happen behind closed doors
that I I would be very suspicious about
you don't know I don't think their
practices are all you know coming from
the Boy Scouts per se you know what I'm
saying and a lot of things this
generation has been about cliques has
been about you know getting views and
stuff like that and I feel like a lot of
the the big gaming media out there they
lost the focus on the gaming industry
and what the gamer is about let me ask
you a specific question cuz you
mentioned media bias and I know that has
come up y'all gonna love the poll later
oh well what stays like like in this
particular case law expert do you think
like what how do you rationalize his
decision to do it like like what do you
think was on his mind I mean obviously
we can't without my readers
based on what the information we have I
know I don't judge people individuals
right because I feel like I don't know
their world I don't know their life he
could he could have had a lot of stuff
going on at home you know the same way a
lot of people do with their regular job
they they have to get certain things
done but there's a lot of stuff going on
at home there's a really high stress
level and he couldn't get it done
himself but he had to make his quota so
he might uh you know chosen the wrong
thing to do
all right yeah we don't know if there
was a lot of pressure from from you know
the people above him as well no it's
something out you know we don't know
about that so I'm not gonna judge
anybody personally this often the
problem with that is that they've
they've already been excited I gotta
give Jason Irish I doubt like opening
when it comes to report yeah he's this
is his ether like he just came well and
more and more facts yes addition
Schreyer how how he said he tends to
bigger Sonia not his to Dax much
whatever you think mother's right the
man's reporting is on point and he came
out there and after this came out um he
then then the FIFA 18 switch review came
into question and then after that when
Philip came out with his quote-unquote
apology video which he will get into
that a second strike came back with yet
another game Metroid Samus Returns which
came out last year for the 3ds can I
just say something real quick I do not
condone plagiarism are AII the action
itself is negative and yes we should
condone plagiarism like no I have a
belief system I can I can look
negatively at an action but I am
nobody's judge I'm not gonna say this
person is a bad person or that person is
a bad person I am NOT I am NOT in a
place to judge anybody I don't know
anybody's life I'm not saying that it is
the thing to do and everybody should go
out there and start copying this person
or that prime not saying that it's wrong
that it's done that but I can look with
with you know that is not right it's
objectively I don't I don't know the man
I don't know what he exactly how nice of
a person is whatever or what I do know
is that what he did was objectively
wrong let's get other people knew
exactly what he was doing you know first
of all let's shout out the Lord dizzy
and a building snuck through the back
and I want to get you an addict in
because you know we have the random laws
we gotta hit everybody side even stuff
that we disagree with and you've been
getting some dizzy salute to the Quaker
let me tell you this let me tell you
this one thing about quakecon and
something about Podesta and if you are a
switch owner I'm not gonna get into
details okay but let me tell you they
love the switch okay so these guys and
things government I'll leave it at that
all right
the eternal joy oh it's it's it's it's
more than that baby opinion on this is a
high maternal
go ahead dizzy so I want to hear no I
died when I made my post I knew I was
gonna get flack but I made it for a
reason
and I simply put I said that I would not
have fired fired Phillip you know
essentially if I was idea the reason
being and it's not because of what
Phillip did what he did you definitely
can't condone that you know me you know
being a former you know PBG you know
from leaping out babies go right oh I
know all of the editing and all the
stuff that you have to go behind that my
whole point and I knew what I was trying
to do is pretty much strike up a
conversation that you know we really are
going at this individual but we're not
looking at the bigger scope of what's
going on over at IGN break it down the
fact of the matter is at this individual
he has never written anything before for
IGN in this kind of manner and the very
first thing that you're gonna have him
do is edit his own work okay granted so
with the video yeah it's probably gonna
be very hard for somebody to be able to
see with the video yes maybe you're
you're probably not gonna find the match
up and everything and this does take
some digging and everything and again
you shouldn't be plagiarizing but the
thing that kind of bothers me is he's
never done this before this is gonna be
his first ride
so essentially daddy gave kid let the
kid crash the car and is gonna take no
responsibility in that kind of manner so
basically you own him under the book I'm
sorry I keep cutting sorry oh no no no
you good
so what's going on with all the other
writers like are they editing their own
work what's going on like this can't be
limited to just him
it can't be okay okay look I don't think
I don't think that the editing has
anything to do with them having had some
sort of vetting process for like
checking for plagiarism beforehand I
don't think they had that
editing is one thing Betty let a diggity
he has got a chance to talk to because
addicts have sent some stuff to me
offline and I just want to get both
sides here cuz dizzy says important
points that's you know a lot of people
are sad but there's an addict getting
them and what do you feel - at the end
of the day this do deserve to lose his
job I believe people who are doing death
threats you guys are going way too far
but anyway why at the end of the day
this dude does I mean he's been proven
plagiarism like three times already so
he needed to lose his job right well I
think the bigger problem is like what is
he said it edgy and easy to get they
[ __ ] basically let's get y'all main
point right so for people that's
attacking because it was like shut his
mic off they go all that did it's the
whole no I just want to clarify this
your whole thing is we're not condoning
plagiarist right
you're just don't think anyone's
condoning plagiarist right we just got
to say that for a relevant maybe because
he doing ha he putting out a news flash
point he go hard but like basically what
you're saying is and he should have
never been in the position in the first
place being that he's really never
written an article and I don't know his
history as far as complete length of
time but from what I know from basically
seeing one on one of their podcast shows
they have he doesn't feel like he's been
around that long so is that what you're
getting that day is that like the agency
could claim some responsibility for even
putting him in that position
exactly i I don't understand what the
the concept and it's not that they were
gonna find anything anyways because it
was an audio work and I mean that that's
a lot that you have to do but if they're
all if they're absolutely stun why
should've been a process at least done
and that's what's more concerning to me
is what about all the other work that's
going on over at IGN are they going
through the same thing or are they doing
their own stuff
yes that's my issue that they may have
this whole situation
it's not what y'all saying this dude
deserve to lose his job but at the end
of the day I just can't like I can't
copyright it knows the first work he
made but I can't comprehend why anyone
is writing and no one's checking their
work like I just don't get how they I
mean it makes no sense to me like you
know this do deserve to lose a job and I
love how everyone in the comment section
is acting like we're literally like yeah
no one is saying that
so go ahead nonsense good job I feel
like I jian needs to restructure how
they do things because this was too easy
for him to do this alright and dizzy i
wanna I gotta get at you because I saw
some tweets now you did say that
basically IGN is kind of throwing him
under like towing him under the bus to
swipe their hands from the situation
that you yourself said I got a quote you
that you would have not fired him so
what'd ya do could you ever trust a
person like that again oh no absolutely
not no if I was ID and I would expect
him to resign absolutely I want to keep
my job then in your scenario like would
you allow him to stay alone no he would
not be getting the pieces that he would
think that Hugh beginning absolutely not
[Music]
quit so you basically met and then and
that kind of manner from a CEOs position
let's go from a boss position on the
front on a position if you catch their
employees stealing because this is this
is theft
alright that's this let's not get to the
point where we're now we've misconstrued
on what he has done he has stole from
another person he has stole from a
smaller persons work he was in a
position where he it was a conscious
thought all right now it's not a
conscious thought as a snap judgment
like a swipe
money from the till know this brother
sat there and actively put a piece
together it was fraudulent when he was
doing it and then he acts actually
produced it all the way through so this
man know what he was doing he knew that
he was stealing and he knew that he has
done it before see he's just getting
court now so this is the mentality of a
thief underneath if he's never got in
court he will continue to steal now I'm
not gonna put the onus on arm i GN it's
not enough on this one i GN putting the
onus on the thief I do but I just don't
go buddy
I don't somebody caught that name it's
not calling him out like I don't get
that I don't get how saying this dude
should lose his job but IGN should
probably restructure how they do things
is a bad thing to say like ideas in to
blame but there needs to change over
there but you're talking okay almost
people are saying that our employees I'm
telling you from Austin's position right
now do you own that do you own anything
listen I actually own businesses that
actually can relate to this if you ever
had somebody steal from you do you let
them back in y'all's you can relate talk
about this is stealing
he's actually stealing understand into
to listen we all I'm gonna imma jump in
for a little bit and then I'm gonna back
to Kings just really pings point but
there's one thing to listen we all
listen to each other and we all have
ideas and great minds gonna make a mic
right there's gonna be some ideas that
are similar but this is structural
phrasing and you know yes you're
structurally taking three
and Plato and putting them completed
some of them the majority of it was from
Batum here here's the deal at the end of
the day there's something called you
reap what you sow like I feel like he
should have lost his job no car mate I
feel like that is like you go to jail
[Laughter]
constantly jump inside somebody's point
now anyway so that you can't sit there
and blame IGN for an employee stealing
now if they would have kept an employee
working after it came out that he stole
then you blame i GM now hopefully there
is things in place once they they have
their like loss prevention people come
in to check everybody's work to go back
because it has came out that this guy
has stole before mmm so it's not an
isolated incident where Tommy made a
mistake no Tommy's been a thief he's
just been a sneak thief so now that we
understand who we and what we're dealing
with you take another company he no
longer works for the company and it's on
the onus of the company if this happens
again then the company is called into
question but he is a thief that guy that
he stole from mr. boomstick I mean boom
stick to the game mr. moon the game when
I saw it I was really heartbroken
because I thought it was mr. bones
such a nice guy you saw a night then
when I am Jew and you like knives not
him I'm like okay cool no but it's not
cool but I was like oh it's not somebody
that we just had on the show or whatever
we getting really messing up and I
watched the video and I listened to all
the stuff and I'm like man this guy
actively consciously thought about this
whole process all the way to that he hit
Send
mmm all right not so we have that that
man is in question that IGN not
afterwards if it happens again is IgM
all right let me throw it back to attic
is he doing what's good his point and
also I got a question for attic this is
from braaap he says attic what is the
solution it's easy for us to say IG
needs to revamp their process but we're
also assuming that they don't have one
in place and what would you do attic to
catch a thief all right let's give it
back to you cuz your whole thing is I
think we all charter John to me we all
agree with each other on some point I
think the issue that we're having some
issue with is IGN's role and I think
that's what Atticus is I think that's
with our dizzy is saying so adequately
back to you to defend your stance what
did you say to that about what could
have a GM didn't better if someone's
just stealing I mean at the end of the
day none of us run a multi-million
dollar media outlet I'm not even i've
never went to school for any kind of
media like I can't give you an answer
all I'm saying is this man was doing his
first has his first article and he was
reviewing his own stuff like how is that
not a problem like okay but how is asian
supposed to catch a guy like that how do
you what do you what can you
realistically do if you have an employee
that you know if you have set guidelines
if they have set go I don't know right
what what can you do how can you do have
a preventive measure if someone China
goes off the cuff and does their own I
think what addict was trying to say is
when it comes down to it and you get
into the editing and stuff like that
there should be a separate team there
and that puts it together to do exactly
what's going on and to check the
information not necessarily the the
reviewers opinion but to make sure that
they are giving their own review and I
think what attic is saying that is that
they are a big enough company that that
should already be in place and he should
never got your editing his own own stuff
as it okay gotcha and then let me give
it back to dizzy because he's the one
chef Enosh out the relevant natives like
Brad said throw the grenade and ran away
[Laughter]
I know you don't got a lot of time I
want you to de finish this and I'm gonna
go cuz I'm gonna go long yeah I mean I
go back to the same thing that you know
somebody made the argument to me about
what I was saying was you know
journalistic integrity
what Xbox said and exactly what attact
is saying is how do you how do you try
to defend it as journalistic integrity
when I mean anybody who works in the
writing or any kind of reviews or
anything like that we know that there
are editors in place for a reason
right and so whether he was caught or
not this is your first piece of work and
this is what they were gonna do they
were gonna have him edit his first piece
of work that just doesn't sound right to
me so what is going on with all of the
other ones are you having them edit
their own stuff also editor like almost
like a checks and balances system like
yeah maybe if he would have been kept up
to date on what he was publishing we
could have caught him sooner like this
is the third one he's done like relevant
in he starts let me jump in I'm gonna go
along cuz this one really bought like
this is tough because I could end the
day I know all the parties involved and
I'm saying and first of all I want to
shout out to my man Lord our Brandon
Tyrell from IGN he did the right thing
he did the we review and also I want to
kind of give you the history like Louis
Lord haw-haw say Otero that's my name
he was the boogie down vet the host of
NBC that's how I first even came in
contact with Phillip right because when
Jose Otero left I'm gonna be real soft I
kind of fell off from the show it lost
its we have an eider hosting for a while
for a host right they were looking for
holes think they really didn't find
their way no disrespect to none of them
got a love Pierre I love all of our met
them all personally a great good people
but at the end of day just didn't have
it when Jose left so then I watched one
time I think was right around the time
when the hacking stuff came out and
that's when I seen Philip and I'm like
okay this must be the new host let me
check him out and I was like yo young
the young boy I got something you know
young Lord is he's good he's energetic I
like the energy he had good news
I was really rockin with him I said yo
Nintendo voice chat podcast stay back
right and I was like he's super talented
and then it's like okay the plagiarism
accusations come out I try to be cool
let's see what he say you know we're
saying but at the end of a plagiarism is
in excuse me there's no defendant I
don't care about your deadlines I don't
care about the stress you are a pain
journalists did exude integrity and
professionalism while most youtubers
don't have those guidelines right and I
said the whole great minds could think
alike but when you copying entire
structural faces phrases copy and paste
that's not a goal right so then it's
like okay he comes out with the video
response so I'm like all right let's see
let's see what he got is safe
you know I'm saying don't get me started
with this damn response no
accountability right no remorse like the
whole thing was like stop attacking me
and my family he didn't apologize he
apologized to IGN yeah I'm sorry attack
it hence one thing but his family I
thought right no one's justifying that
but he's not taking accountability he's
not saying I mean I don't really think
it matters of you text accountability it
does because Emily is ridiculous but
that's not the point you put yourself in
that situation you're at night you attic
Philips actions you know saying made him
he's got to live yes down there so
that's what he did now granted no one's
saying attack his family members you
know how to internet his internet stupid
and I'm saying I'm not justifying that
them to go after that man's family but
at the end of the day it's like watching
his video was like watching a drug
addict who's a play jock plagiarize got
a problem
Thank You x-bar it's like you gotta have
honest valance valuation in yourself dog
at some point you have to have admission
of the it is they put up a video called
grand theft author you know plagiarize
that's usually not the first time you
got the Engadget article with this
famous returns phrase they're from
Nintendo life for 5 for 18 it's this
whole thing man it's just sad it's like
I really like the kid thing that hurts
that is that I know everybody I know
expa how you feel like this is why
people say media buys this is why people
you know this is this is what I was
gonna say you notice with this
generation like I said yo these systems
come with game DVR and stuff like that
there is a lot of passionate gamers out
there there are a lot of gamers that
don't have that sub count that are doing
quality facts oh yeah and what what I
want to say is and this is reaching out
to the gaming community right I know we
have leaned on IGN on GameSpot on all
these
like baking media sites but it is so
wide open now why not go and support
those youtubers that are now I got I
feel you going and I just gotta cut you
one second because end of the day listen
you I hope you're right
you are right but I gotta divide you in
this at the end of the day let's be
clear this is one isolated man's issue
this is what we got in it Alana didn't
Alana also leave again and she was
hinting to the fact that they were they
were looking for clicks and views yes
that's me children
yes look I understand Dizzy's point and
it's an addict sport with that the
overarching narrative that IGN is
overworking its writers Alana before we
after she left she specifically said
yeah it was really hard like I have it
was a lot of stuff I was in the office
all the time and I go back to something
that King said way back when he's like
this is a this is the leading media
company in gaming Thanks
you know how they stay there mm-hmm by
trying to be ahead of the curve right
especially now that they're under attack
by people like us doing what we do like
they have to they have to evolve they
have to change and in doing that the
work environment is probably pretty damn
stressful then it goes along with the
territory of being number one so it you
know I understand I understand that you
can say yeah you know the star in
practice that need to be addressed I'm
sure after this they're a lot of things
that are being addressed after a lot of
the issues that were going around going
on at IGN with the sexual harassment
claim and things like that issues were
addressed
right mm-hmm so right trust me that all
of this stuff now moving forward is
gonna be handling it in a certain but
thing is big day at the top there at the
top if you want to be there guaranteed
you're gonna work really really really
hard right right let me let me finish as
a point put shout out to Santa he's
making some great points that I don't
wanna shout their exact sentence at
funny stuff all right he's saying it's
simply not feasible for idea to check
for plagiarism before most piece and
pieces go live he said this this is Lord
out of this something he's saying this
guy does his thing especially something
like a review where you assume the
evidence slash reviewing question
understanding
credibly basic concept concept of
writing your own work and again I just
want to be clear like I said we have to
I know IGN is getting it right now and
rightfully so you know I'm saying maybe
there is processes that need to be
changed all I'm saying is there are a
lot of people over there that do
fantastic work and I'm saying and it's
just it's sad to see everything that has
happened as a result of this but to me
it's more Saturday I can't defend this
guy that I initially like because he's
not even taking accountability if he
would have just came in to be wrong I
did it I gotta make it right with y'all
I know y'all don't trust me right now or
just say hey this is what happened I was
completely overwhelmed whatever but to
not even say those words nor apologize
to the youtuber he is and to xboxone
point I can't blame my chin all the way
to because he had no experience really
in there I don't say not no experience
but they basically grabbed him from
YouTube that's how they found him mm-hmm
they found him from YouTube now whether
or not we're dizzy and addict maybe
right is whether or not he deserved the
shot is another thing right but at the
end of the day they've tried to give
this you time a guy and then he went and
did his own thing and like I said it's
just a sad situation that's all I got on
it unless you guys want to sharpen some
more let me know I think based on what
he had done on YouTube and how he had
performed that IGN to that point
interview was nice a charismatic
charismatic rocking with this dude I was
like yo Nintendo voice check his back I
think there was no reason to assume that
he didn't deserve that shot oh man and
if you look at if you look at his video
reviews right a lot of the written
review is is just verbatim what he says
in the video because he's like again
it's something that you're that you're
recording ahead of time so you're not
you know there's not a lot of like oh
he's just you know he's talking as if he
were writing so a lot of just translates
to the page so there's no reason to
think that he was incapable of writing a
written review shake says the same thing
he said I was perceived to I was hurt
after seeing the video slow-mo he didn't
admit the plains reason but he thinks he
has a shot at another job in this field
no he's finished now that you may be
right nice mop he's not doing it because
he's hoping his career finished but he
has to pull the video down you know that
right
shout the phone so he had the you were
pissed me off he had the nerve to
monetize the apology video you can't be
monetizing the apology video I me addict
days I'll let you rock out and then we
can move on yeah good I mean if anybody
wants an update of what IGN is actually
doing they're actually from what I lost
saw the co-ceo or the co-founder of IGN
actually is reaching out to the two
boomstick about monetization I mean if
they if they really want to make things
right hey I think boomstick has a job
now deserve a shot and I want to shout
out mostly because the end of a the only
positive thing I see out of this is the
board guys jump jump so yo shout out to
him like I got a go and I want to check
out his channel yeah cuz you guys know I
I am down for for comments that came
down for true gamers making content of
Zak's and giving their opinions doing
decent reviews and stumbling so I got I
gotta check out his channel yeah
absolutely like I said that's the
positive thing you know the guy like you
say that's why these guys you know
saying it don't got the subs and don't
get that look and I'm saying at least
this guy now people like y'all it's
crazy because nowadays people are
blowing up on YouTube when it comes to
console wars and what they call the
chrome side of things the ogor dealing
with drama so that's why it's good to
see like iron Lord podcasts even
initiate some extent next podcast you
know we're putting that common sense out
there we're talking about gaming and and
you know we do our best to avoid of
course things are gonna overlap in
certain situations I talked about kind
of like I'm really disappointed at a
certain youtuber out there he goes by
the name of the red dragon because I
used to I used to watch his stuff all
the time but if you watch his Twitter
now he is he's taking a hot poker into
the council ward thing because he got
triggered emotionally where he used to
be out there with common sense now he is
he is falling more towards the line of
dealing with drama and stuff like that
and he doesn't have to his channel made
it you know what I'm saying so I feel
you go with that first of all salute to
the red right I like the red dragon I'm
gonna put an attack on red rag because I
really got respect as far as what you're
saying I know where you're going with it
I heard I've heard I'm saying and I've
heard you know I haven't heard much of
it all I can say about actually red
dragon gonna be for sure at some point
and I don't want to mess that up but
it's not about connections and stuff
like that but one thing you're you're
always gonna get from me your whenever
you have me on is I'm gonna be honest
I'm gonna be honest too and here's how I
feel about that at the end of the day if
he started his channel on doing one
thing or enjoying one platform and then
all of a sudden says hey you know what
I'm not feeling that platform I don't
like it anymore I like this that's what
he has the right to do that now yeah
there's gonna be repercussions and stuff
after that based on your base and and
make based on how people perceive you
but I can't sit here on my platform and
attack a man for wanting to do his
channel his way that's what I'm saying
and we can I would love to have him
mourn and maybe have you heard it and
really have you guys talked about you
know what you guys feel about I was
watching his like conspiracy videos and
stuff like that you know what I'm saying
I was watching his like complete like
spectrum of content and like what I saw
on Twitter we're asking like any topic
we have hopefully at one point and like
I said hopefully you point you guys can
talk it out and whatever tries to get a
job just keeping it cool
but on yeah that's all I got really on
this on IGN plagiarism stuff Lord saw
what's going on real quick just to put
the exclamation on the last topic
it sells please fantastic okay so this
this topic is kind of twofold first as
me geeking out fanboying out and factual
stuff so the first thing is that I shout
out to redditor Cobra for basically as a
rumor out there that there is some sort
of letter of intent by Microsoft to
purchase obsidian students in studios um
bottom line these guys were born to make
RPGs that's what they do that's what
they do best
um these guys have produced some of the
most hardcore sort of isometric RPGs um
they produce sequels in known series
already just like Star Wars Knights of
the Old Republic - they did Fallout New
Vegas they've done pillars of eternity
their own stuff these guys are RPG gods
and if this is true man oh man to have
them in the Microsoft fold I kind of
lost it because I was obsidian obsidian
is if you look at them and the stuff
that they've done they've always been
sort of I don't want to say beat here
but it's really no way to take
technology they've never had money it
never had the money around him to really
do really make a huge huge product um
you know they did Fallout New Vegas on
the Bethesda and while people thought
that the New Vegas story was better than
for our three story yeah did the Sith
Lords our Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic which wasn't as well received
as the original Knights of the Old
Republic but there were circumstances
around that um so the thing is just if
this is true I'm just thinking about you
know a hundred million dollar budget
you know obsidian RP I'm losing my mind
I don't know what you guys think but
this had me geeking out because if
Microsoft needs this well I'll pass it
yeah they wouldn't they need a true like
a big stage kind of they just need it if
they have a true R
PG studio in their fold that's just
gonna focus on making stuff like that
that's a big plus no doubt now let's be
clear on the situation so what about
this first I want to shout out tick
podcast last night shout the sand shout
the cow beat money - crew anchor when
you haven't seen one um but I just paint
goes out on a date and they really went
in on this and for my understanding
since what correct me if I'm wrong this
whole thing centered around a letter of
intent solve like this was it was
apparently some floating out there
someone saw this guy Cobra whoever right
saw a letter of intent from Microsoft
right purchase obsidian entertainment
and I want a salute Lord Sam because
again he's been upon this even fire on
this thing so pretty much you know I'm
saying this guy who bleep this thing is
pretty credible right here I believe one
of the playground studios things before
it happened when that happened and stuff
like that and again shout the Lord sent
please watch to class like last night it
was really good podcast was they yeah
they brought out was that on with is
that for mine saying that the Obsidian
guys will has signed it
yeah I'm saying so get X but like so
pretty much day alike yo we would've got
a movement your pitch for them to be
bought out which is great oh wow okay
mmm-hmm backwards okay yeah so that's
fantastic because that means that they
do and it makes sense for them because
again a lot the last few things have
been pillars of eternity and whatnot
it's open crowd funded when these it's
funded very quickly because people know
the expertise they have the feel they
know what they're capable of doing so
again they it's their realization that
when they look at something like a ninja
theory
well they look at something like
compulsion games and what they're gonna
be able to make moving forward having
Microsoft's backing yeah I'd want a
piece of that pie too
yeah that's alright you know I got you
bro yeah definitely give a shout to
Jonathan B obsidian slitting them DMS
don't like news like this you know what
what do you feel about this this is
something that and I feel like this
person is not getting the
or kind of like respect for doing that
is Phil Phil Spencer and some Xbox Lord
Savior
a lot of Savior that's what this is what
Phil is looking like right now right now
is the camera up are you back in the
bushes if my camera is up I can
guarantee you I woke them would you put
it up and stop talk about what you would
do
woulda coulda shoulda this was wrong
with your generation you always
criticizing but never Phil said this in
the beginning he said he was gonna deal
with the power narrative which he did
right he was gonna um you know for the
shareholders on Microsoft side of things
getting you know the Xbox app on
multiple devices getting that whole
thing rolling and he got that done
so the next thing he said was you know
bringing games to the platform and
people he did two out of three things
and then people were kind of like
questioning if he was gonna do the third
now do the first he had to take money
from the budget and make sure that the
Xbox one X got out in a timely manner so
they didn't have all that money to
spread around in terms of getting
Studios getting other games kind of
unlocked down and stuff like that so
right we're kind of dealing with um that
that hole that the whole reaction to
that action right now you know what I'm
saying we we have like CEO thieves
we have crackdown fourth horizon forward
but people are asking for more so what
does he do this III you hear five
studios and now fitted call a moment
yeah and then ninja theory which was oh
my goodness cuz I'm a huge Ninja Theory
fan I didn't necessarily like how blade
but I have been witness to theory
throughout kind of like the life of that
studio man even going back to like
kung-fu chaos you know I'm the og Xbox
in the top do I love what they do
um so even though obsidian is the one
that signed this deal I do gotta say you
know I can see Phil kind of going
over there and starting the talks with
them and the in the talk being so good
that obsidian signed that deal and said
yo we're down you ready he's exciting is
definitely so let me get addict on this
because I'm I know he's got he's Prada
he's been in this boat before with his
beloved fable you know and playground
that announcement and stuff like that so
um what do you feel about you know this
announcement with obsidian thinking um I
don't really want to speculate on like
literally no evidence but there's a lot
of David's evidence there's a letter of
intent that well not every what day is a
letter intent that was found but I mean
as Microsoft confirmed that this
document exists well it's the same thing
with fable when we talked about the news
when fable came out we didn't have any
hard evidence at that point but we
talked about yeah it's just I mean what
comes up City and they're good developer
they may follow it New Vegas which is my
favorite Fallout game yeah but I mean I
don't know I don't know if they can
create their own IP and do the same if
they don't it's to you like they took
the Star Wars brand because they were
contracted to make that game they did
really well they took the fallout brand
because they were contracted to make new
vegas and did really well but like
certain devs can't make their own world
and do very well right so you you're
skeptical you're not it would be they'd
be a nice pickup they would because i
feel like they can make good RPGs okay
but i mean i don't i don't know you're
like pump the brakes let's see what they
do first well I mean let's see there's a
couple things I gotta see what kind of
game they're gonna make some Studios
would be like yo they're gonna make some
good RPG and they're like we will make a
racer like even if they're purchased I
feel like between them and playground
and the initiative that's gonna be like
their pillars when it comes to action
games if they don't if they don't get a
ninja theory on that you don't get a
second studio in our add up City
innovated they say they do get picked up
and they're making RPGs like they're not
doing anything else that was open DS are
you still in the Builder yeah man I'm
still here Oh we'll have to see I
I'm curious on I would want them to stay
towards their first-person RPG because I
really like Fallout New Vegas was about
to ask you because New Vegas like that
when I saw that was on their resume I
was like yo fallout fans that is
arguably their favorite fallout and I'm
saying we had anchorman we be going
crazy right now so it's like
anything we're and see here's the thing
like fallout 3 fallout 4 all of four is
my Wars failure Robert Stubbs fallout
getting so you know I feel like fallout
3 was good but Fallout New Vegas was
dead that's who created the faction
system like they got in fact Got Talent
and I think the like the isometric RPG
that they've made for years
it just doesn't by look alone it doesn't
appeal to everyone right it needs to be
grander it needs to be either
third-person RPG or first-person RPG
that no isometric stuff just doesn't as
soon as some people see that they run
away like I don't you feel if they took
one of the existing franchises it made
it like an open bro hey I'm all about
reimagining stuff you know how I feel
about old I Microsoft IPS being dormant
and I'm not doing anything with it so
I'm about that how would you feel if
Microsoft scored a a dough Disney and
they rebooted a nice little republic
like a Star Wars game not exactly
because they can't do Knights of the Old
Republic there's a lot of issues that
Disney has with that world this is not
about the violence and that's not all
Republic was is we killing everybody
fast so if they were like rebranded it
and brought it to the new age how Disney
inspiring this he can make game they
just want certain guy lights to be
followed how would you feel if they did
that I think that would be great and I
think that would be an option for them
because I think that the CEO said it a
fergus or quad he said it before he's
like I like making games in other
people's worlds because you you have set
parameters to work with but then they
give you the freedom to do what you want
within those parameters so
it's you know like you said maybe
they're not necessarily equipped to
build their own IP and build something
huge out of that but they seem to be
happy working in other people's worlds
as well so no yeah I just want to say
are two things I'm against you I get you
know down yeah oh yeah pretty much
something like this ain't over to change
like what if they made like uh something
like a Fallout New Vegas to or have them
make them something leveraging I don't
know about them yeah that's interesting
but you know but that's do it because
let's be role
Microsoft is okay with releasing
everything all but Sony platform and the
white but test is going they might be
cutting Sony out in the next five hey
talking card game stuff right now
this is like it's crazy right now but um
you gonna get you I'm gonna get you a
shout to kiss moving to chat what up K
um was gonna say yeah Xbox go oh yeah
sorry my whole thing is for people who
follow what's going on with Xbox they
have this thing called game pass right
and if you hear what though and and the
people Xbox what they want this service
to be it's going to be the Netflix but
on the gaming side of this so I don't
understand why people would be surprised
to hear these rumors or anything like
that because if if they want game pass
to be what they say they want it to be
then they have to be the company with
the most first party studios under their
umbrella alright because when it comes
down to it you need exclusive content
and you need it you need it there
numerously and you need it there
frequently so X at the end of the day
like this didn't surprise me I I'm we're
gonna hear a lot more about a lot more
studios and we're gonna hear rumors and
we're gonna hear things
I don't know yet yeah it doesn't seem
like it is I need you your feeling on
Excel got you know what do you feel
about that in just in general you know
what the Obsidian the culture going on
you know I actually I'm taking it a
little bit of a different angle does
anybody else feel that this is like it's
like sports season offseason times yes
it feels like offseason talking I find
it's kind of interesting because I do
remember watching a documentary series
thing
on YouTube they were actually
interviewing obsidian and this is back
when they were kind of talking about
what was the Stormlands that they were
supposed to make and they weren't kind
of sort of throwing a little bit of
shade over the situation going on with
Microsoft so then I I found that that
was kind of interesting and everything
but like I mean it's cool I mean I'm
just ready to see with all these
acquisitions or anything like that I'm
ready to start seeing what they're
actually gonna be doing and everything I
guess that's where I'm pretty much yeah
you're not on this design that's cool
for you but it's like yo let's see I am
Number and a curiosity extra on Planet
Xbox out of all the games that they've
announced who you think's gonna come out
of a game first at all the studios they
now besides for is because I was on a
obviously that's coming out a while for
the five studios but I do know on Ninja
Theory they just like maybe three weeks
ago or so they put out that they're
hiring for somebody in kind of like the
melee combat type situation um so they
might be farther along in terms of the
only parent of the game that they're
trying to develop but so did bring up in
a in an interview that he they've been
working on that game since hell blade
saw stopped well well that's still none
that that much well I mean that is a dev
time that's not a lot of time I think
the I think the only studio that that is
the farthest in their dev time and so
I'm thinking maybe 2021 with that I
think I think what's gonna happen is I
think Scarlett is gonna come out in 2020
and I think you have uh it's an awesome
lineup with that I'm talking like the
new Forza Motorsport I'm thinking the
new Halo and and fable in terms of their
launch lineup and then I think in 2021
you're gonna start seeing the newer the
newer acquisitions the newer studio
start coming out with their games as
well and I think they're they're just
gonna hammer it man I think you're gonna
okay I think we're gonna see ninja
theories in 2020
let me get King and make him acquiring a
chance to rock
Oh topic of obsidian being purchasing is
it possible what what what that holds
for the future
Oh who did that for you get a chance to
control the nor interrupt the network
income what's the best part about you I
love my little spotlight it's like that
light I got right there that's adding
I've named that light attic on me
so you just like the light and I can
always count on you to be right there
spotlighting me I purposely shut up and
let you talk you are purposely shut up
and let you go on your whole little rant
about what's coming out next and all
this other stuff run your mouth and I
purposely watch you keep on running all
over the place I purposely did that i
sat there and read this book while you
wear your mouth let me get to my topic
and let's turn the spotlight off anyway
so you know Phil is our head with the
purse strings and he's purchasing these
companies and I know a lot of times they
can't really speak about it until the
deal is done because that last minute
you you know things happen and you don't
want to talk overstep before the ink is
dry right so I'm pretty sure just like
ex-parte to highlight xbox point um to
be the Netflix of it Netflix when I was
purchasing a bunch of studios and
people's like are they purchasing this
they're spending money there was no
fruit being bear and you know people was
like I they still in line with Hulu then
thus the the studios started producing
and then you started seeing shows and
then Netflix took that supreme jump so I
think he's setting up his guns he like
he like legs my said he took the
narrative then he allowed you to see the
plan because everybody wanted to know
Xbox
box plan the plan was to get this on
everybody's device right so in doing
that you get a streaming box that is
cheaper that you can you you have
flexibility with it you can get it all
over the place and then to have it on
tablets or whatever wherever you can
play as long as you engage with X spot X
Box it works right and engage with Xbox
you need studios and I'm not surprised
but is are they going for the best and
the brightest or sometimes overlooked
Studios that's what you're gonna get
arraigned again mm-hmm that is a good
idea and I know y'all said well what has
they done that was an original IP
opposed to tagging on to something else
maybe they're given source material and
since they are good at other people's
source material
maybe that lends to a halo where the RPG
feel to it maybe that is that fable
maybe we don't know but owning a studio
is better than not only in the studio
and allowing them to grow so I just say
it's it's a positive I don't see any
negatives in acquiring studios and
Jobson points he's saying he thinks the
cloud consoles next year Xbox - I'm just
kidding he's like on playgrounds second
eye he might be a 20/20 one game
depending on how long it takes
and he says Daryl Gallagher student will
be the last guy I do agree with him I
think the daryl the initiative is gonna
be the longest one in trucks they still
kind of form it and so let me just can I
just jump on your point because I know
he's gonna talk about the initiative
with my place we can move on but yeah
man I mean this thing sounds I mean they
were talking that quadruple a talk we
kind of laughed that dumb because it
sounded funny you know saying but at the
end of the day when we see these
acquisitions you know I'm saying he got
the lead producer that was on rise of
the Tomb Raider
they got all this other chick she was a
recruiter who did for I think or respawn
and Riot Games Microsoft Studios then we
got this guy Christian I can't
and to Mesa yeah right in designer on
red dead and shadow of mordor that's a
big deal thing and in like a Sicilian
director of portfolio planning you know
apparently this guy has given assistance
for Witcher 3 Lost Planet advised and
indicating wise a Tomb Raider like Elder
Scrolls for like these are huge names
you don't say and last to I believe it
was on trial like Crystal Dynamics
people and I'm assuming you know that
worked on the rise of the Tomb Raider
reboot and obviously that's what a lot
of Darrell Gallagher's history comes
from listen the end of the day all the
stuff is exciting like I agree with Lord
King this is completely what you need to
do whether or not I rather it's like
like I almost like did he said yeah
doing all these acquisitions and people
like yeah but we need to see the games
at the end of the day I look at it like
look you have all these different
companies working in the choir and then
you have more chances of one of them
making something fantastic mixing
something great and to the lord xbox
point I do agree with their role on
services and pushing game pass it's like
Lord Xbox a it's gotta be like a Netflix
like service you got to have original
content and the press rubber it so that
stuff grows and grows and makes people
say hey I can't not have the service you
don't saying because of everything their
producer so I like what's going on it's
cool on Lord King you've been patient
Nintendo what they doing what's going on
I've always learned something when
desperation sets into somebody or
anything you get this chance to see them
act out of character mm-hmm
they do things to keep that attention
there and since the stocks went down and
what you know they they heartbeat is
deepening is deepen murdering cayde-6
right
you know what exactly to your point and
let me tell you when desperation sets in
to a company you are going to see what
happens so what do they do they kill
player to Luigi they killed him and they
took him down now shout out to the no
because I got that that they kill player
too from the no no because I almost died
it tears when I heard it in a soy and I
said man they're desperate they're
selling the smash brothers when a system
is nice the package looks great and they
look like they're betting everything
heavy on this farm because it's all the
way into something so they've trying to
keep your interest and they keep letting
out little snippets and they say
castlevanias here you've been asked if
whatever we killed Luigi we kill player
two we've been growing up with this and
I'm not even gonna get into the part of
Paul did Luigi's death but the
desperation at Nintendo are they trying
to get likes or they're trying to raise
the stock prices they said we will raise
us up prices by getting interest back up
by killing a beloved somebody in the
shareholders you know sauce all over the
place he's dead he could get back in his
body and I want to know is it
desperation are we seeing the Tendo
showing us what is going on Nintendo
came out and said he's not dead yes bro
is crazy
yo we we actually recovered
next podcast as well and and K mega
thought I was crazy for bringing it up
but it's exactly what King said you know
it's something that we've never seen
from Nintendo before and I think at the
end of the day there might be a little
cross marketing here in terms of another
kind of like Luigi game that might be in
develop you say the we just mash music
to addicts is right there yeah yeah and
I think that's what's going on of course
they're they're marketing Smash Brothers
but at the end of the day that that
cinematic at the end is what caught
everybody because people are like no
that's not Nintendo they don't do that
and I know it caught me and I kind of
like what they're going with that man
showing that they will accept like
expand marketing Master Shake I'm not
committed to slandering Nintendo and I'm
in a little and I got a hit as literate
understand and interpret here and they
sure from there and I gotta feed it all
coming from a space of love to Nintendo
with my beloved system all right here he
comes he's not here
okay JC playing they step away from it
he be back but Lord did you in the chat
lit they go you know I mean I Game of
Thrones and work for Game of Thrones
kill off a character yeah maybe maybe it
is a cross-promotion get another game
like I said
Luigi's clue game you know who murdered
Li Jie and where was it got a warm
good job maybe he'll be a ghost
character gay
can we make some sense to his commitment
to the troll is like when we say King is
a man of his convictions we when he
trolls it's a hundred percent no from
what I heard it could be hinting at
whatever is going on in the story mode
and smashed like you know fit you know
people get murdered left to right
because I think if you really want if
you really really really want to set
people the blaze you murder Mario like
you murder Mario and then you're like
yeah you can't do that name so who is
that metal explain cuz the first the
smash video from e3 like Oh Ridley came
in I think he murdered Megaman and I
think he damn near murdered Mario right
people excited for the game again people
story mode is something I don't know how
story mode went over in the Wii U
version right but I know it's something
that people you know like death took off
its hood and it was Mario under there
when Simon Simon Belmont jumped in and
killed death so this is Simon Belmont
avenged Luigi Luigi was trying to get
back into his body but it was a eyeball
that was crying I mean a war face that
was crying outside the window he got
scared and the fair going on for a long
time
Xbox basket because they had a great
segue door this is always shout out
Carey begging them like let's get to the
overall pig with the Luigi aspect like
how long is this man gonna be just a
citizen go for it
what if when did they kill the Luigi you
guys really took that way in content but
you go team wants troll is say it's so
desperate that this so behind cuz the
stock went down Xbox is working if it
worked for destiny they said destiny was
desperate and stop slow they killed K
they killed the beloved guys didn't know
though right
Oh desperate thankfully because the
Tendo was getting heat and thankfully
they came out with a 3-2 dead educator
in America did his face said no he's not
dead I'm wonderful my people needed to
hear that from them like just because
they've never really done anything like
this before two gigs boy like they've
never really
[Laughter]
back to back to your point Kylie do like
why this man always the steps this is
his this is his station in life this is
what he was created for to see mara he
is he is Charlie Brown trying to kick
the football he's the big joke of the
universe and I just don't get it but get
attic English lost again okay there you
go
no there's nothing really take about it
like he he turned into a ghost on a
Super Smash Brothers trailer like I
didn't even I literally didn't even pay
attention to that because that's how
super smash brothers are like it's like
the most violent thing they make yeah
now I'm gonna ask you this question and
simply move on from this home obviously
we know about the bundle you know I'm
saying and we don't think we got chance
to talk about that is in reference to
like yo like they they got that limited
edition bundle you know say in a common
with the game would have died at launch
without the GameCube controller really
60% of the the Super Smash Brothers
community will not play without the game
really it's - I didn't know that I did
not read my first mask the Wii U they
brought it back for the we're really why
accidentally you could hook up the
GameCube controller so that's what's up
so hey guys look like they got the
adapter looks like you got the little
foreplay tat you know means you can get
your couch co-op going on beat it up so
they go run with that man so you know
that think most like you can sell like
hawks
what do you feel about that xbox I feel
like it made sense man people who are
into Smash Brothers like our attic said
there was a way to play with the
GameCube controller
throughout throughout its history or
whatnot so it just makes sense to do it
again I think the controllers are hot I
think for people who are serious about
Smash Brothers because their art
tournaments and stuff like that that is
the controller that they are used to and
it only made sense to come out with the
four top and those controllers you know
for everybody to play like like they've
been used to me no doubt no doubt
what do you feel about the assault fill
out that that that bundles going to Sun
[Laughter]
probably outselling the game proverb
like mmm it's a lot of people again if
you're big smash player your GameCube
controllers are probably in the bushes
by now so you might so yeah in a bundle
I think it the tennis move all get this
thing moving alright so I was really
jumping this is I make this quick um
pretty much what's been going on and
what we set off the overlay show the
adequate net is this whole thing with
steam right now and I want to set it up
I think discord set it off this week and
pretty much they have this new online
store that they're launching and um it
was no interested me because of the fact
that you know we all know how big this
code is for online chat and video
services against a lot of crime across a
lot of platforms they got 150 million
gamers I mean they've been growing so
they actually said it they've been
actually mulling the idea a long time
you know they're gonna have exclusive
games in it they're gonna roll a beta
out for it in Canada and um their whole
thing is to get into the online store
business you know I'm saying and you
know what I find is interesting is kind
of not only with the dis courts growth
and I'm actually kind of really I don't
say challenging steam because it's doing
early but they're really positioning
themselves right and they're looking to
have a beta launch up exclusive titles
all this stuff and you know it's kind of
the preferred chatting platform on PC
but then you got things like you know
let's look at you know destiny to write
and call a duty on on which closet
battle that battlenet you know you look
at EA origins and all stuff you
have this pattern of flux out that
people don't want to give steam that cut
like the big pushes like they don't want
to pay that 30% and I just interesting I
want to bring this to the Lord you know
like is in trouble and and one last
thing I want to make is that I want a
shout out Lord press Katella you know
from turn around and read these finest
you know he actually optimize with the
discord things he was like yeah it's the
okay I'm opening a storefront is a big
deal he's like with every major
publisher seemingly going with their own
PC launcher he said this is the place
where this court is the place where the
friendslist lives it has the most
engagement our favorite where it's all
engaging and so this go yeah so pretty
much like he says he feels this is a big
disruption coming to PC so I want to
bring it to the Lord's let's start off
I'm actually switching I'm gonna start
off with Lord King you know I want this
chord to do well I want this court to do
so well that steam looses stock and get
desperate and has to sell a Markus wolf
and microscope kills off the rental
store and upon that way back in one big
point I forgot the whole thing it is
story but that's the score came in I'm
kind of confused yet this court a minute
because you're asking like how they how
there you disco is actually opening
their own online store like a methanol
steam no steam has been on I would say
the decline but as far as basically
where they were like I said that may be
2016 2017 they may be had 150 this Court
is there now 115 like this Court is
growing growing growing and like I said
like cristela Otto people said that is
the default for the most part place to
party chat in the chat on PC that's like
a fact this court is that big but then
okay I'm legit okay their problem is the
same thing that steams gonna have a
problem with more and more big
publishers or leaving that platform and
they're not gonna go to diss courts
platform they're gonna keep on their own
right and I know what you saying and
here's the thing but they're also trying
to start their own like exclusive games
as basically they're gonna call like
first on disk or titles
yeah something that could buy and I saw
some of them names and I got affected by
this already because banner saga 3 was
one of those titles um yeah I know how I
feel about this is the police I parade
that thing and we were supposed to go
this is the police to this month DC got
it launching is gonna be launching for
them and now and now the console all the
console versions have to wait until fall
that just recently happened you know six
I was waiting like and I'm speaking to
the dead like what's going on way all
right like I know it's supposed to
release this muffin is like Oh for PC
and I said no wow so this there's some
slow ripples going on but King imma get
back to you I interrupted you I wanted
to do above and beyond and I want to
full so that they have to bend in and
that's what I'm about I'm a fury but
what about what about Bethesda now
saying hey we're not putting Fallout 76
on Steam at the same time so it might be
a little cryptic little message let's
fall to the ground they acquire them and
regardless to what it be on Steam
because it'd be all Microsoft same day
but this is one of the few companies
that can get away with doing that uh
because the games don't come out that
often and it has fallout in front of it
like any any of their huge games that it
can get away with like we're gonna do
our own launcher because regard
of where we put the game people who want
the game we're gonna go get it
regardless to what so they can get away
with that smaller publishers not so much
so I kind of agree with Alec would attic
where I say like theme is too big of a
juggernaut to sort of be to be toppled
by this will it is it gonna create some
ripples yes um I I still think if
anything is mission yeah you can I just
think the steam is too big to really
really be moved by this because that's
actually I think at some point all those
games they'll come to steam okay and to
clarify because I wanted to defend them
I don't know we still have deep but to
clarify at QuakeCon people did ask but
that still like hey um
is this mean or but there's you know
they they say they clarified they said
no just fallout 76 right now based on
the online structure of it and that you
know they still intend to bring stuff
because did you know anything in
reference to quake on it I mean yeah
that that's pretty much right on point
and the thing is like a wither their
online port that they would have they
have to run that on their own a lot of
the online ports will actually have to
go to steam and so again you get more of
the cut that has to go back to see me so
that's why 76 it doesn't make sense to
put it on something like Steam now is
this going to hurt steam no the big
games have never been the bread and
butter of steam it's always been the
Indian Idol smaller budget ones I'm
working with the indie developers is it
gonna even amount a little bit yes
because I mean any any kind of talk is
definitely gonna you know do a little
bit you know as we see you know King
getting all crazy over about Steam and
every day
[Music]
but I'd be afraid to say I I mean I
think that we're gonna see with like a
lot of the big publishers as we're
already seeing on PC they're moving
everything to their own storefront we
see that with you play we see that with
EA access we see that or whatever they
call it
Origen sorry disrespectful so you're
gonna keep you know Blizzard net they're
just gonna be moving on the PC over to
something where they're not gonna have
to shell out that extra percentage
they're just gonna run their own
storefront right so let me I mean
specifically what do you feel about the
discord threat specifically because it
because how they've permeated and
they've infiltrated that PC market and
they are the de-facto you know chat
platform like people are not for the
most part using steam like that for that
chat aspect like they're going to disk
going and they're growing so like all
you feel are you you're not agreeing
with like Chris katella's forecast like
yo this is a problem it is going that is
going to depend on how they handle the
rights with the developers and if are
you gonna be charging what's the cost
whenever you do updates what kind of
system are you gonna be running as far
as like the updates you know it's like I
mean when you look at steam steam is
pretty lacks whenever it comes to things
like that whereas you look at something
like if you look at the the PlayStation
Network or you look at you know
Microsoft Live you know they have to go
through a whole Q&A session in order to
get directly everything so and then are
they gonna be charging you know the
developers for you know things like this
a lot of that is gonna really depend on
that yeah it's great to have that that
list there because I mean you know that
the people are there that's you know
looking at the whole twitch first mixer
thing yeah
mixers great for streaming because of
the Latin C but people just aren't there
that exactly the engagement where the
people are that's a great point X but
I've been holding you back
so I'm sorry just want to get some
poison had everybody else but um yeah
well yeah man with this I gotta say
first off competition is good in Greece
in any kind of like genre and any kind
of area now if you look at steam
steam hasn't really had any competition
when it comes to the PC side of things
we've seen you know battlenet we've seen
origins and all that stuff pop up and
you're gonna see more of that pop up
because the PC is an open platform right
when it comes to discord I am any any
newcomer in there even though they do
have a base that they use for
communication and game chat and stuff
like that they are still new to the
store area okay fair enough
so they're not gonna make an immediate
impact I think a lot of people are used
to playing games on Steam and using
discord to talk to their friends
Crichton um at the end of the day people
are creatures of habit so it's still
gonna be like all right well let me get
my game running up on Steam let me go to
this court and get to my people good
point over over time depending on what
discord does and how much they are
really committed to this store and
everything like that over time it could
wear away at sea but in terms of an
immediate impact you're not there yet
yeah you're not you're not gonna get an
immediate impact man I guess they got me
because I'll just finish it's our claim
they got me because I was such a
distance police fan when I was bad and
he's like we'll have some announcements
soon Mike I'm ready
you don't say LP coverage hey y'all know
my dizzy no y'all know my late night IOP
nor Cognito after dark tweets with this
is the police you get good at it when it
comes down to this
I don't think this but there's the
Saints but the fallout 76 I don't
believe in one second every game every
pathetic games come on that platform
I've known it because it because it's
dedicated servers in the online
structure Peter I just came out with
this statement like a few hours ago that
shocked everybody like a they saying now
maybe future of the bestest yeah they
said it probably becomes game no see
they say it's really 76 II know I know I
know I'm saying that all Bethesda games
are going on the
platform they're making my fallout 76
like they could say what they want
they're not gonna make this for one game
especially when they get that revenue
there we would have made this much as we
save esteem like they're they're gonna
use the platform they built for that
game they're gonna start releasing
everything a lot of people are really
forgetful how much Bethesda has an
influence they own the dishonored game I
mean they polish the dishonored games
they progress the Wolfenstein games they
published the Dune games they publish
all out they publish Elder Scrolls this
and those games are no problem they're
saying Pete hands are saying we will not
bring me a skipping steam with 76 they
said and they have their own dedicated
server in there saying what I'm just not
coming I feel like if it was something
no I'm not saying it's coming I was
saying if it was just fall out because
the topic is the steam in trouble right
and I feel like if they were just doing
a one-and-done thing they would put this
on something like a battlenet that has a
really good infrastructure for Internet
they would make a whole infrastructure
for this one game unless they had plans
going into the future to bring all of
their games to this platform they breed
every pathetic game that's EA that's
already gone that's what des that would
be gone Ubisoft is in and out they have
all their games on Steam as now kid
smooth said that a fox tie oh what's
that place that made the Warner Brothers
just signed a deal of EA so their games
are not coming on so you've seen
obviously you like yo stay you better
pay attention like look like today score
is not their trouble there's trouble was
these big publishers leaving their plan
actually now see what you call my bad
another thing to put off what addicts
said when it comes to steam what new
innovation have they done in the past
like years or anything they just they
did they got to a certain point and then
they just stayed there with it you're
not you're not evolving or anything like
with the industry that I've seen
maybe somebody else who is really in the
PC gaming can tell me different but what
I've seen they got comfortable kind of
like when Sony did with music and stuff
like that they got years that they
haven't they haven't made games like the
way they did you know they've been
living off of dota or whatever and they
haven't been actually made a lot of
games they focused a lot on on a VR
which is fine or they have these the
most advanced has set out there but it's
not you know it's not it's not it's not
hidden now what it's not hitting like
getting like at home so yeah kind of
going with the flow
I guess already left destiny and color
dude here on battlenet so you know like
I'm telling you sooner or later the
majority the big publishers that have
like 10 games under the that they
publish it yearly EA's been gone now
there and you know people are like old
games need to be on Steam I'm willing to
bet you if they if EA wouldn't have left
Steam Matt wouldn't be coming out for on
put on PC right now shout-out Diago
kajal's could see bunch a discord is not
the enemy to steam steam zone anyways to
wait exactly discord that could really
help them discord is that they open up
you know you know that console like
experiences with like the unchartered
The Last of Us and that was only on
discord that would do a damage because
steam doesn't really have that kind of
quality of exclusives statue this is a
good one very interesting I thought you
know celebrated on the table let's see
what happens but like I agree with X but
you know competition is a good thing
let's speed this up you're still doing
we have people with few impressions
whatever yeah that's fun this be the
last one we got here so what's your
feeling what's going on I like it I'm a
couple hours into it the game has a lot
of issues
shout out to I think it's gearbox they
sent us the review code I can't remember
exactly but I mean the game has its
issues a lot of people were I feel like
this game is getting attacked what's not
really being attacked it's being
criticized for like the reason that I
see so many people talking about is
because Microsoft at the company at e3
right so they're first off this game
wasn't built with any
kind of Microsoft money really second
this game it's it can show you
anyone that's actually played is anyone
on this panel played it I have not
played it way back in the beginning when
it first went in to give me two I
replayed it sitting on that plane yeah
you've got a problem
this game has those moments tor like you
know it's it's really story centered
okay
it's about you know you you're in this
land you come across some items that
remind you about your past so you pretty
much break out of this this drug called
joy and the the rest of the game is you
trying to get out of this land that
forces there civilians to take joy
mm-hmm so and you know there's certain
sections of the map where you have to be
on joy to get through why we think it's
like colorful it's nothing like you did
I do feel like you know that aspect I
wouldn't mind if their next exclusive
for Microsoft is we happy few - but done
correctly okay I feel like this came out
a lot of potential is clearly under
budgeted they didn't have a whole lot of
money going into it that's the reason it
was in the preview program this game it
can really I was you guys remember when
compulsion was announced I was like I
don't know why they bought that company
Yeah right right right actors play in
this game
I'm like this they have the foundation
to make something that can talk by
biology so years notice you're saying
you see that potential and just to
clarify this was not made under which
say this was not made under the
microscope we hear that like people like
you were here in the crashes or whatever
or you know some critical reviews people
like oh this is the studio Microsoft the
game it was designed it was in the
preview program so that's how you know
how it was funded it was it might have
been funded more on the backend with
Microsoft after they bought the company
they're all ok you got to push this out
the door we got to get go right so you
know that could happen but I don't know
anything in statistics on that because I
don't worry
no I doubt that this is a gearbox club
with published game like they had to
finish out that contract before they
even think about what you know what the
wins the next thing is but the game has
a lot of pitch it kind of reminds me of
like a Dishonored
and there's nothing acid trip man when
you take I feel like there should be
more repercussions when you're not on
joy because when you're on joy if you
come off joy you're going through
withdrawal syndromes when you have to
pretty much hide until into you're like
it's I like it I think they should have
the game should have been built around
Joy's like how to get into certain areas
you have to be on joy it should have
been that times 10 and I think this game
would have been anyway from a 75 to an
85 I believe their next game is gonna be
a tour bus
there's no tell it to the judge the
biggest and biggest MVP today like he's
been killing he said people already sing
is this your king they really need to
you know define some stuff especially if
they do any kind of sequel I do think
that they can make that Bioshock quality
that it's being compared to yeah and you
know a lot of people forget this is this
is pretty much their first first first
first I got I got it I got a question
for adding if you know do you do you
think that um what you consider as like
the low points of this game do you think
that over time through patches and stuff
like that they might be able to make it
better or a lot of issues with this game
is built into it I mean really it sucks
I don't think this is worth 60 from what
I played with it I think 30 but you know
it's definitely worth playing for a good
third you can get it for like $30 on a
sell this game is an easy pickup it's
fun I've had a lot of like what moments
like the hope point you're unlike think
of it like the the five circle hell or
something like that I don't know where
y'all
the fifth circle and the only way to get
out is in the center points every every
like three or four hours and they make
you do some crazy stuff on these check
Delilah's like those that's all I'm
saying
the game's good it's worth playing
they're gonna keep supporting it I heard
it's getting Story DLC mhm so yeah I'm
excited to play it at some point I think
what addict mentioned the story stuff
and and comparing it to Bioshock I think
that's what Microsoft saw in them the
ability with the budget clearly they
have their neck I think they're next you
know I do because you know it's like
Lord King said he talked to one of the
PR people at e3 in she was like yeah
they wanted a bias and the first thing
we asked him you know what we know that
was me yeah that was me that was
actually me and Lord Sam we ran it
because King ran into he had the big I
wanted that but oh yeah I had a
compulsion it was me and Sam we bumped
into one of dads and his little like
what she said it was she just literally
said we told mark something like hey
guys we make right leg so I kind of like
that energy you know and she just used a
brewing like a she she used a beer
analogy she said basically before the
acquisition they were like a local
brewery so to speak and then she said
the acquisition for them was like
Microsoft pulling up as well while to
say yo you can do whatever you want have
access to all our resources rock out you
don't say and she was just like they
were like blown away so they the biggest
thing that I would take whatever they do
I hope Microsoft gives them for a full
you know freedom like they're doing with
the majority of the studios and I'll let
it they got to make an M rated game why
because they cannot make a T rated game
you know attic that's exactly the vibe
she gala we are gonna go there so you
can't be coming in you sure you want to
sign us now what I feel like this world
should have done is when you're off the
joy the world shouldn't look like
something like the evil with it like you
want to be on the door because it's hair
you so care
aiming game pass within the next six to
ten months it would be a perfect game
for game path to get in game pass right
now fax all right but let's get to the
polls get out of here um new poll this
week in lieu reset plagiarism issues by
a former editor at IGN who hold most
responsible the answers are a hygiene
should have vetted the editor more
thoroughly to avoid the issue be editor
broke
IGN protocol on his own in the
journalistic
see just another example of media bias
on Twitter Lord X pot it's absolute
pleasure in the realm that have you
integral all over do wick and what do
you have going on well first I want to
say huge shout out to the chat you guys
have been absolute fire today and as
usual the piano I've been with just
about everybody on the panel in in an
Xbox Live party chat except for dizzy I
believe but I'm Samos yeah look man you
bet me shut up but yo guys you made it
feel just like an Xbox Live party I had
a lot of fun it was it was very
comfortable I was able to share my
opinion and you know I always appreciate
that um you can definitely find me I'm
on a couple shows of course the next
podcast every Saturday 7:00 p.m. well in
my channel we look at gaming news
straight with gameplay for you to watch
and you can look for the best gameplay
after the show I am also I'm also on
crossfire
every Friday I'm mother mooches channel
so make it a part of big gamers small
talk and that's usually just Sunday or
Monday correct I bring that common sense
to that show
in their place on that show no no yeah I
am a part of something called CCC which
is uh it's it's on vacation right now
until the fall it is coffee casuals and
consoles it is podcast BIOS snaps I
think she's gonna be doing some changes
we we were usually going Wednesday
during the day I think there might be a
time change on that so stay tuned for
that and as usually you can always
follow me on twitter at XY four four
eight and I I can't wait to come on
again hopefully absolutely nobody knows
never one time being with the realm of
the Lord's man also like I said what we
try to do is promote when we speak when
I when we feel topics kind of suit to a
guest we had which is a cameo like we
did lowered dizzy if he was still here
been the Lord is he been you know from
the very beginning he believed in us
leaving the ILP movement I don't want to
never not give him enough credit cuz if
it was a fan like you really help put us
out there give us some life so boy did
he what is going on you're getting back
in the game again what was poppin we're
gonna find people finds what you got
going on well you know it's really hard
to follow that spot with all of that uh
all that podcast stuff that he's got how
do you have time to sleep sir I do live
sir house or do you have time to sleep
[Laughter]
we starting to ramp everything back up
of course you know I mean whether you
know where I'm supporting plagiarism
apparently you know I just had to throw
that out there but yeah I mean yeah yeah
I've always believed in this movement
and everything and it's not about me
believing is the way that you guys
handle everything and the way that you
present yourselves and I'm always gonna
be right here in your corner and
everything love everything that y'all do
yes yes so of course that you know
Twitter we give the handle yeah you'll
be able to see the playback gaming
podcasted we've actually moved away from
doing the website you know that's a lot
of stuff that goes behind that mm-hmm
that's kind of why the topic that we
started off with that was a little bit
passionate about it and why I was
disgruntled about what I saw was going
on but of course of course I we're doing
to a every week we were doing every
other weekend so we're gonna be doing
every week we're not a live show so
essentially you know whenever we have
the interviews a lot of the stuff is
pretty done and everything but we want
to make sure that we have the high
quality we're also gonna be kickin with
if you haven't heard we are one of the
take affiliates one of the newest ones
on that one so we're gonna be putting
out a little bit of content on that and
everything and I know what the you know
Kings out here you know pumping the iron
Lords podcast destiny Klan membership
and everything like that and the reason
why I'm not in that there's there's
other reasons and there's a content that
I'm actually working on and hopefully
soon I'll also have a little bit of the
channel 5 slash iron Lords podcast will
be part of that I'm so be looking
forward to that that will of course be
on my youtubes a little YouTube channel
hopefully nobody plagiarizes that I'm
not gonna spill the beans I know some of
the stuff we talked about offline what
you got cookin but I'm really excited
for you to get that going because um I
guess it's really exciting and like I
said you just give me a call we're gonna
try to get that thing done really
appreciate you back doing this stuff and
you know for the record my boy not
defending plagiarism so your
just bringing in adequate bringing
someone points me that's dope I read so
Lord add it
what you got going in what's going on
with the front which got going right now
I'm playing some knife game on my phone
but I'll be launching a video tomorrow
on you know improvements that they can
make on record too it's actually it took
me four days to make this video so
definitely I catch into that I'm on
twitter at Lord addict IOP so you can
always follow me on there definitely
follow me on there I'm a approached in a
thousand what they could do fast
probably by yourself I have no do if I
can find me on Twitter Lord saw ILP
playing a lot of freaking Metroidvania
is on switch and this week I will be R
is the shameless switch I know I will be
I am done with I'm done with the city
story I'm just gonna play everything
online
the baby's gonna play the game that
everyone not played again everyone plays
together alone with God I need my
sources of hero stuff going I still
haven't done any of the latest night
falls and stuff like that so I got all
that I will be on Oh real quick - big
shout-out to our man Jay Fonzarelli
check out his latest video on Red Dead
Redemption he breaks down the gameplay
trailer he goes in rock star man every
time a rock star game comes out it's an
event and they just stay they went above
and beyond feel it man killing it so rap
said you need to pull your destined clan
weeks off
[Laughter]
you shut up dr. Fontan that too because
I know I'm a Red Dead fraud I mean
trying to attack you see it is this I
was like you know I'm glad he put that
out there
you know I'm saying this show the
appreciation good point sorry you know
I'm on a podcast with a bunch of red
dead haters never really played the
first one like that so I couldn't really
go in but I don't hate I say this for
this specific reason everybody when I
mentioned Rachel a fourth I said we
would frighten on the red Lord King we
can apply what you got going on well my
my fraud alert is on through the roof oh
my god
I'm gonna have to call out rap eggs by
to call our Lord sovereign Oh
we will see all right Lord Lord grep
said he's back to date uh we will see
sir King oh I got that predator son go
show by the way you sir I would like to
see you engaging more with the clan stop
stop fraud Lord sovereign yeah I'm gonna
hold you to your word you said last week
busy so let's hopefully you got your
cloak of invisibility check it out king
of all media
let's see you on the face
book the Instagram that Twitter um if
you're not following every Lord head
start following every Lord head we read
tweet tweet tweet double tweet tweet
tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet
so are we actually out here Tweety um
get out there is Matt funny and if you
ever want to see the most random content
out of the blue just get on Instagram
you'll see stuff that you like what we
have no reason to because I know that
retaliation record will make sure
everybody is used for promotional
purposes only it's not a situation where
you know we are out to actively get
people to hang out and stuff Facebook is
used as a community where you can go in
there you can interact with us and you
can see what's coming up
alright so that's what Facebook is about
that's about it you know I'm about to
get upstairs first I'll probably do some
yard work and if I don't feel like doing
that if I see the frauds on King check
the chat I gave people the reasons as to
why they see you know they actually got
a chance to see me drink a whole gallon
of water during the show
so and I told you that was monkey punch
that'd be actually stuffing his face I'm
blowing it up and that's actually hot
monkey love
two monkeys they always got some wild
stuff that's actually eating chips or
whatever the hell I don't eat so what is
it like I said you know shot it again
Lord explored is he coming through
especially this last minute and X bar
man long overdue you would definitely be
back in the round y'all ready no you got
history ton of fun and I'm saying salute
to everybody
so yeah made home like I said make sure
you guys hit the like subscribe
subscribe to all the anger podcast
YouTube channel and the actually inner
circle network affiliates let's give out
affiliates or some shops brat podcasts
energy for guys with quarters in the
gaming perspective podcast as well as
PBG in the building you know saying so
yeah I'm saying so also long shout the
Lord kibosh when oil that be going up
later tonight into iTunes SoundCloud all
that good stuff with the timestamp oh
you get long but um yeah man flashpoint
26 and 27 with ebon says are back up on
YouTube IOP YouTube this week we had a
lot of the content salute my boy
advances he's working hard out it was a
little double-dip addition because we
had the combat stream early in the week
and then the throb was huge to this week
everybody was using was no way we could
not talk about and lastly got Lord king
will combat talk be returning in a week
or two so combat so people's been in my
damn crazy but the thing is this I want
you two guys to understand I'm not gonna
bring you any subpar content I'm not
gonna bring you any subpar fights all
right I'm not gonna give me anything
that you have to stick your head up and
say what did he tell me to watch why am
i watching
I can't give you I'm not giving you any
slick oil Sylvian homes on price but if
it's a good bond fight I can't give you
something I know that player eight is
gonna destroy play a beat
it's not you know I want y'all to
understand that I take this fight stuff
very seriously and if I see it that it's
something that is worthy of your time
because you can't get back time you
understand I'm not gonna give you that
stuff you know fair enough and you all
right just let us know when the next big
one comes I'm gonna promote that thing
people loving it you've got enough
okay September I'll get good and that we
might be doing that one live some right
let's get that perfect so that's what I
got I said everybody enjoy your Sunday
if anybody in rest of the realm has
anything left to say speak their peace
if not we are here
[Music]